le premier il se situe en zone dunaire
avec d un certain nombre de campings
avec un peu pas mal de points sensibles
à défendre et donc des difficultés de
pénétration à l'intérieur et de l'autre
côté on a un autre feu qui lui se
propager dans des pains qui ont plus de
20 ans et qui sont n'y a pas de
discontinuité au niveau de la monaque du
couvert végétal et donc ça veut dire
qu'il se nourrit dialogue qui galope
qu'il a
en après midi avec un parti faire un
tour de l'île aux oiseaux sur le bassin
d'arcachon donc on avait vu la fumée au
sedif rôle à l'arraché page du conflit
c'est bien noir on est rentré
sans trop d'inquiétude
peut-être que cela fasse il peut être
pas et puis finalement 4 heures du matin
nous a demandé d'évacuer